[Music]
welcome back to careful boys okay we got
to be careful i'm very careful is that
like the irony and the thing yeah yeah
it's a new age and we have to be
extremely considerate and careful she
can't be danger no no no no no no no we
the danger boys we're the careful boys
it's a new era man and you know what i
like to bring back is my character the
woke moose
there's a woke moose i have the woke
mousse is there i have a walk in the
woke moose
no because it's a new time
and i realized that i gotta mature and
i've been making too many immature jokes
and i haven't been considerate about all
of our fans out there who just need a
really safe
space to come to that's a good example
of a woke joke
a woke joke yeah yeah like a knock knock
joke
but who's on the other hand you just
can't offend nobody that's no exactly
knock knock who's there sorry yeah true
no no i knocked i asked cause it's like
someone just knocked it and they're like
get the [ __ ] i don't even know what the
[ __ ] what are you doing out there i know
the non-castle law
yeah see that's not what knock-knock
jokes are intrusive man a woke joke is
like this all right um an indian man a
white man but you can't do that right
what about yeah all the priests walk
into the bar jokes those are gone oh
here's a look joke all right here here's
three
non-binary individuals
walk into
a place consensually consensually
to have a round of drinks
to have a conversation
one
well let him go that's it you can't even
say anything else one test of two beats
right how are you doing and then the
other one says
shut up and give you my safe spaces may
i may i ask you
that's just a joke all right
that's it three individuals
share
their life
experiences and talk about
psychology
how how deep
that's a joke
the woke highway how how deep rooted is
this uh like there's been a lot of
comments i think like disney in
particular and other places for really
shoving it in your face with movies and
tv shows i i don't have it you got a kid
to be honest i don't even know what woke
means what does it mean
that's a good point because it's like
wokeness can be
used like
so like how people just
if you don't agree you're a nazi or
you're a fascist they just use it right
so it's like oh this guy's annoying he's
just [ __ ] walking yeah yeah right it
gets thrown around like that
but in my definition wokeness is like a
it's like an extreme militant version of
imposing what you virtue signal into the
world and
originally i thought what real wokeness
was was digging through and
understanding like you go down the
rabbit hole of tracing like the motive
of why you know this special interest
group is paying off this politician and
you dig beyond what the media is telling
you filtering filtering propaganda a
little bit right it's like the matrix
yeah the red pill blue yeah exactly i
think you're right though i think it's
an extreme version of being pc or like
just for
my
ego like to make me feel moral
superiority so i think there was there
was a time in which like uh somebody
like had become woke maybe before it was
like quote-unquote world culture but
maybe somebody had become woke and they
started understanding things you know
outside of the matrix and like seeing
the lies behind the whatever but now
there's something like whoa culture like
what
the theoretical woke is seeing things
for what they are past the media the
truth right like the the behind the
scenes handshakes but i think woke
culture now it almost seems like there's
like this aggressive take on it where
like
you have to like in just a little bit of
virtue signaling like i see the truth so
i have to force you to have the truth
and if you're not willing to take the
truth that i know then you're part of
the problem right that's kind of like
yeah is that that's my gauge of like i
think we're all similar paige i think we
all kind of think i think so because i
would defy wool culture as someone who
wants to impose their
uh morality on you and if you
question it criticize it or say anything
against it then you're all of a sudden
the uh
the the hitler so like so like right now
like so for example right everything is
about um being inclusive with
diversity or whatever that means let's
celebrate maybe someone who might be fat
right and then it's like okay cool i
don't care uh put a fat person on an
advertisement it doesn't bother me much
right but then i think awoke would put
that on steroids and go
well not only you know should we just
include him there but we should just say
that like this person is the epitome of
what all men should strive for because
they are beautiful too and it's like
well hold on there and then getting mad
at another uh advertisement firm for not
putting fat people in there yeah yeah
yeah or for putting like a bluff person
and oh that's not ideal yeah yeah well
like let's say this fat person now wants
to lose weight and they go oh now you're
fatphobic
yeah like adele when she looks yeah yeah
how'd you get blasted dude people get so
mad when someone loses weight like that
i know they get so mad they're like
betrayed
because the other one that i experience
when i experience but what i like kind
of see out there is almost like
want to give you some money and i'm like
no i'm good i do good for myself no no
you don't know i know what's best for
you
like that's what i also see too right
where it's like it feels like wait are
you really trying to help because it's
like they're almost called white guilt i
think that's white guilt but they're
using like uh um
by the amount of
support
they're actually being racist like no no
you your culture view you as subhuman
and you need help
you guys can only stand up through my
involvement i need to help you yeah yeah
yeah like that but i really hate all of
it and you can't really tell although it
gives a vibe is that it is all optics
like if you truly cared if nick truly
cared in that instance then i don't have
anything wrong like if it in his heart
of hearts
believe that all right
in his heart of hearts if i said i'm
good he's like okay cool right but but
he wouldn't continue it right it's an
optic thing to get off his conscience to
get off his ego to prove that he's a
good healer but what if i had a camera
while i was having this conversation
with him
like subscribe
for more white guild let's go yeah
that's my channel
subscribe
whitekill
my channel is it also another uh you had
mentioned this word uh earlier
overcompensation or overcorrection
are we in like a time of potential
but i wonder if it's gonna continue if
if media does it so much and i don't
have kids i don't want to go to bar and
they're shoving it in little kids faces
in a way i wonder if those kids will
grow up with the same or if the kids
will grow up and rebel against it
or they're just way better and we were
like holy [ __ ] we should have woke up a
long time ago
yeah yeah there's been so many movies
that people ripped for [ __ ] like that
they just throw it in your face yeah i
think there is over correction because
uh
i don't think like i think everyone has
a point i think everyone who's hurt has
a point i don't think everybody's reflex
to being hurt is the correct answer
there's a lot of misdirected anger
that's for sure because like
there's a lot of shortcut thinking right
when especially when you're frustrated
or emotional what ends up happening is
you don't get to think clear and then
you revert back to defense mechanisms so
like let's say
you're triggered because something
symbolizes something to you for example
um you know we have in-cells in the
asian community who see
uh
asian girl with the white guy right
they'll see asian girl with the white
guy they get triggered and then they go
oh she hates herself i know you know
like they automatic it's like
do you obviou do you really believe that
every single interracial like
relationship has no love and it's just
like a like a colonizing example
like no like come on dude like get to
know the individuals have a conversation
don't just write them off and don't
treat people like it's not all
mail-order brides exactly
but there's so many speak for yourself
right okay
speak for yourself and i think there's
so many instances of that because what
ends up happening is somewhere along the
line someone gets bullied someone gets
hurt someone feels entitled or something
right and then they see these symbolisms
like all over where they get triggered
by it and they use shortcut thinking to
go oh i see what this is you know but
it's not
a lot of the times it's not
the
what i realized is that people fail to
see nuances
because it's so much the world is like
black black and white right like like
meaning they think in um
what do you call it like everything has
two options or binary binary everything
is binary right
it's very like democrat republican it's
it's always like oh you remind me of
someone who's like a trump supporter so
therefore you are because what i'm
seeing is yeah it's also being
recognized by the media and people so
for example with the whole casting of
joel rogan right he's a bernie supporter
he's been a democrat pretty much always
but then he's all of a sudden a
right-winger
and then people who don't do the
homework they go oh i'm not going to
listen to joe rogan he's that
right-winger guy that gives a platform
for all these extremists and
misinformation and whatever they're
doing that to russell brandt too russell
brand he's been talking against the
media he's been you know well not really
against the media but against corruption
with facts all this stuff questioning
certain things that we as a democratic
you know process nation should question
our government right and he's just doing
like research and having conversations
then the media comes after him and goes
oh he's a conspiracy theorist he's a
writer yeah make him look dumb or crazy
today's video is brought to you by
expressvpn
alright so as you guys know
i i was lucky enough to be in a movie
called the fabulous filipino bros
unfortunately they were only first
released in asia and i have no idea why
it was all blocked in u.s and i was like
trying to figure out what to do but
thankfully we have a solution here i
know most of you guys are just thinking
like why don't you use incognito mode
let me tell you something incognito mode
doesn't hide your activity but also you
can't even watch content from other
countries just by using incognito mode
it doesn't matter who your internet
service provider is isps in the us can
legally sell your information to the ad
companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so the isp
cannot see which websites you visited
expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time i
don't even know that i have expressvpn
on it runs seamlessly in the background
and it's so easy to use all you gotta do
is tap that button and you're protected
expressvpn is available on all of your
devices phones computers and even your
smart tv so there's no excuse for you to
not be using it protect your online
activity today with the vpn rated number
one by business insider visit our
exclusive link
expressvpn.com off the record and you
can get an extra three months for free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
off the record expressvpn.com
off the record to learn more but he's
more communist and left than a [ __ ]
could be ever close to a conservative
but then now there's all these like
things in that are going on where it's
like oh if you disagree then you're a
hitler if you disagree you're a fascist
yeah that's the thing that i think i
think is weird too is i don't remember
that happening a long time ago where
like if you even slightly if you're not
on the same team then you're the [ __ ]
enemy it's like dude that happens here
like on jk news like we'll just talk
about certain [ __ ] people disagree
they're like oh you guys are
anti-vaxxing [ __ ] right-wing whatever
whatever i'm like god damn like have a
conversation i mean i'm the cool thing
is like i'm down to change my mind all
the time like i'll be wrong i don't go
oh [ __ ] i didn't know that all the
asians were first getting beat up like
um i was like oh [ __ ] this is
this sucks like this is pretty crazy and
then i hit up uh tim kennedy to do that
situational awareness seminar thing a
little background around uh tim kennedy
what is he kennedy is a former ufc
fighter uh former greenbrier which is
special forces
so he's like pretty much like as as
close as you can get to like jason
bourne or mission impossible in real
life like jumping on the helicopters and
[ __ ] like overthrowing governments
from the inside out like that's as close
as you can get to why'd you say it's so
casual yeah yeah because that's what
that's what i know but just how you said
he's like he basically just overthrows
uh shitty government
so you're you wanted to help the
community by having someone who's
military and trained and all that stuff
really good at work help the community
protect themselves maybe
or each other so for me i believe uh
problems most problems are solved on the
individual basis
and so when you're responsible for like
if i'm responsible for my bike your
response for your bike response for your
bike
then statistically when you look in
retrospect there's a lot of safe bikes
rather than i think how people like to
solve problems is like this place has a
lot of stolen bikes all the time and
they just do like a blanket solution
bikes are outlawed here now yeah well
they can't get stolen if they're not
here really ever fix the problem you
know so so when i saw that i was like
okay cool let's get an expert and let's
teach some basic things that even an
asian grandma or asian grandpa can do
and so that was like my way of like
trying to help our community and then
after that uh i would get dms of me not
sharing
stories of the asian like grandparents
getting beat up that much when i'm like
i'm pretty sure like
the stuff that i'm promoting or the
things that i'm commenting or even like
getting someone at that level to share
actual tasks solution-based solution
based is actually
more effective than just going
which i feel like is almost kind of part
of that world that's a way that's a way
bigger than that now yeah they're used
to fear like mongering in a way like
don't drink coffee joe or you're gonna
your head's gonna explode and then i
just show you videos of heads exploding
uh
see it's happening really the scanner's
clipping like that's how the news works
it's funny because we
want actionable plans yeah so then so
they're like well you're not spreading
awareness you never talk about it on jk
news we talk about all the [ __ ] time
but we also are a comedy channel so
how many videos are we gonna post of you
know asian violence like that's good if
we did that that'll be like 30 [ __ ]
videos a month there's so much it sucks
right there is an argument to made that
like awareness not that it's useless but
like what's it gonna do like like those
jackasses that are doing the violence
watch bart's video because he reposted
like yeah i'm not going to punch today
i decided not to punch nobody i got into
a fight with a communist because it's so
hilarious right because i i was making a
joke about um china bots and then he was
like that's the kind of rhetoric that
gets everyone to hate asians [ __ ]
real and i'm like but china bots exist
they exist yeah yeah i think the
awareness is is helpful but i think the
second like people start getting
slandered for not promoting awareness i
think that's like a different version of
harmful that's been so huge the last two
years yeah that's someone else's metric
of what is considered helpful for this
movement one and who's to judge what's
like priority or not there's crime and
bad things happening everywhere 100 so
like
my instagram's now a news feed and i'm
just going to repost any news that's
ever happened bad to any person anywhere
and i feel like it's unrealistic for the
logic to be awareness
uh deters bullies right right i think
the logic dissolves anything never
happens the victims and then the bullies
will right right you give [ __ ] deer
machine guns i don't think lions are
gonna eat them but if you go lions don't
eat them please that's not gonna do [ __ ]
dude
that's like that's like recently right
and you're only talking to other deers
yeah exactly talking to the lions i
recently i recently saw this thing
where to combat asian hate they got all
this [ __ ] money millions of dollars
right and their solution was to educate
people on asian america and i'm like the
dudes fighting [ __ ] beating people up
are on drugs and they're not [ __ ]
reading this material he just he doesn't
go to uc berkeley yeah they don't have
the pamphlets over there
if someone's truly like racist like true
you're not gonna sit down and convince
him otherwise especially not through a
textbook yeah
like the [ __ ] especially not through a
[ __ ] commercial but definitely ig
stories will work and ig's story like
someone's gonna watch [ __ ] tv and see
how like
asian hate commercial and go you know
what i'm not gonna beat up asian people
today it just makes no sense i am going
to violate parole but i'm not going to
beat up agents yeah
i was going to rob an asian lady but you
know today i'm going to rob a white lady
instead that's what i'm going to what
commercial did i policy scales
it's like sheep trying to [ __ ] keep
wolves away
i think this is the good definition like
locust because they just feel better
yelling at bart that they didn't i know
when he's trying to because i love
asians you don't love asians i love
asians more than you and you're asian
it's about how good they feel rather
than how effective it is yeah yeah right
i yield that bar quantity
i feel like it's a combination
i took his last name
yeah it's definitely a combination of
fear because it's like you're afraid to
actually do something that will
challenge you and you have to sacrifice
whether time or money difficult right
and then another thing is no one really
wants the responsibility so what i when
i see all these like videos of people
getting [ __ ] up right they go oh if
that was me i [ __ ] do it around me
[ __ ] right right that's one and
then they [ __ ] blame the people
around them like pieces of [ __ ] they're
not these [ __ ] [ __ ] what are they
doing just standing around and i'm like
that's humans though like most people
have been in that situation it's rare
i've only been in one
most humans don't understand violence
most humans don't know what to do and
it's like that's why movies they they a
virtuous character is courage right
because the reason why it's virtuous is
because most people don't do it that's
rare so it's like and here's the other
hard part the same amount of uh media or
videos that are being shared of like
those incidences it's like you're also
hearing stories about people who step in
and then die sure yeah you know what i
mean so you get that regular human fear
too you know what i mean i think it's
obvious that we want courageous people
to go out there and do something right
but then at the same time
you know
blaming the people that are afraid is
also [ __ ] up oh yeah because because
everyone in that it's like no one knows
what to do they're not trained to kill
somebody also everybody that i've seen
who is trained and could very well
defuse any of these situations with
whatever skills they have always gives
the advice of get the [ __ ] out of there
yeah i've heard a lot of people say to
be honest that's that's what you get
don't get involved when the person who
can do it when you ask them what should
i do they always say if you can not be
there just go yeah get safe call 9-1-1
but i've heard from a million people
who's never fought or been in violence
being like oh i would have kicked his
legs and i would have been like that and
i want to be like how about that how
about that [ __ ] cop that's going
viral the black dude he's going to be on
next week dale brown he's going to be on
the next one here we're going to get him
dude let's go commander yeah
i thought his name was
we mix them up we should have him
and teach ages on not to get beat up oh
[ __ ] that was fast though dude
meanwhile he's [ __ ] used that even
that guy i see him as like miles above
all the other [ __ ] comments because
at least he is trying to provide
solutions he's doing something that's
true you probably get a lot of people
killed but he's trying something i think
every time i was like he moves this gun
like this way now he's shot in the left
eye instead of the right eye and that's
that's what he wanted he did this though
he's still one step above just [ __ ]
spreading awareness it's true that's
true yeah he's trying
let me spread awareness and comment on a
neck shark article
that's how you do it though
you